we'll start right here with of course
the big story march madness is here
and we've waited two years for this day
selection sunday
remember last year march madness really
was madness as the
pandemic caused everything to pause and
now the tournament had to be canceled
but
it is back here we go
march
[Applause]
how about that this is gonna be a wild
ride
what a game
oh how great is it to see the turning
back and selection sunday everybody
wondering where your school would be
seated
or would it be left out the top seeds no
surprise
and the overall number one seed is
gonzaga with the bulldogs
heading up the west region and the
number one seed
the baylor bears for the first time in
school history illinois is fighting
illini
the number one seed the number one seed
is michigan the wolverines ah there you
go they're your four
always a few surprises in the tourney
here are a few of the teams that may
rock the boat
the feud last four in first four out
colorado state louisville st
louis ole miss hey checking in on the
mountain west two teams making the field
of 68
there were three mountain west teams
sitting on that bubble it burst for
colorado state and boise state
but the aztecs are in the midwest as the
sixth seed
and utah state the aggies as the 11th
seed in the south
byu making its first appearance since
2015
earns a sixth seed in the east they've
got to play one of the last four in
michigan state or ucla the winner of
that game the committee says despite
kovitt
they had enough games to work with 98
percent of the tournament games were
played so there was really really
quality information on the resumes
out of the top 100 teams in the net the
average number of games played by those
teams was about 23 games so there was
quality information there that we were
able to work with
oh there have been too few selection
sundays for the once proud unlv
basketball program
remember the days about six years ago
when it was a foregone conclusion
that on selection sunday drama centered
around where the rebels would be seated
who they'd be playing
not if they'd get in the running rebels
of unlv
the number five seed still go up against
the number 12 seed out of the pac-12
mike montgomery's california golden bear
oh that seems like forever ago thinking
back to that year it was dave rice's
second trip to the tourney unlv's last
they faced the bears in a rematch of a
game earlier won by the rebels in the
season many felt it wasn't fair
the selection committee would send unlv
to san jose right in cal's backyard
for that first round matchup rebels were
favored but ended up losing
well the face